Nè sợ iran ngày 1, 2 cho biết đã bắt dữ một chắc mang mấy chiến công dân nước ngoài tại Tình Jad,
ở miền Trung nước này, viên quán tơ các cuộc biểu tình gần đây, nhà trước chắc không công bố cuối tệ của những người bị bắt.
Theo chuyện vi cải sát giá, à mẹt nha gà bán, các đối tượng bị khảo buộc tham gia tổ chức,
kích đậm và nhiều phối thành động bạo loạn trong một số trường hợp có liên hệ với các mặt lời ở nước ngoài.
Ông đòi như hoa đậm này nhằm gây mất ổn định tại việc phương.
Chưa đón như lãnh đạo iran cho rằng các hình vì bạo lực trong là 16.5 vá trò của xin gần dự của X-ray and Bạm Mỹ,
gà bộ hai nước tình đậm bộ đổn trong nước và chia dẻ xa hội iran.
Jad của đón một trong những địa phương chio anh gương của các cuộc biểu tình gần phát trên trọn quốc tự tham mấy hai,
giò khó khăn kinh đế, sau đón nhánh trong chuyện xa mổ sát chính chi,
và bị giới trước tên iran trình á mạnh tay trong tháng một.
Sống như thế mà theo thống kê chính thức của bụng ngoài xa iran là hơn băng ý một trong người trong khi các tổ chức nhìn quyền cho rằng,
trong người.